[Applaudissements]
bertrand est ce que ça vous dirait de
venir à côté de moi pour faire du niveau
de bertrand avec plaisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut je me sens triste mais agile
gillet est assez nerveux aujourd'hui je
sais mais je sais pas où valérie elle
m'a dit pas tout chabert trop c'est
vraiment elle m'a envoyé un texto tu
toucheras bertrand jeudi mais quand même
elle n'est pas la voie là et je sais que
vous pouvez faire le cobra aussi on m'a
dit oui c'est vrai j'ai expérimenté
cette technique sur sur valérie salles a
porté ses fruits
est ce que je peux voir là ça fonctionne
et ce serait pour la voir venez me faire
un bisou
[Applaudissements]